hey everyone I'm Justine welcome to my
kitchen yep there's a portal gun in my
kitchen I don't know how to cook as you
guys have seen in my past videos but
I've been attempting you guys sent me
this recipe it's a combination of three
of my favorite things
ketchup peanut butter and cookies so I
mean how can this possibly be bad I
don't know you guys don't like to see me
attempt to cook something in a future
episode just leave me a comment below
and maybe I'll attempt it but for now
let's work on these cookies shall we
start now I think we shall alright our
Ivan's bringing now we have to stick
together our ingredients the baking
powder soda
we don't really measure here I even made
some t-shirts I ain't about this
measuring life there's also an apron in
a cup so I will be using that in my next
episode but if you guys would like to
check those out feel free to in the
meantime who ain't about that measuring
life I ain't about that measuring life I
think that's a tip that looks like a tip
to me half tips of salt you look like a
tip I like salt it looks like this I
know it teach them shut up I'm not
stupid
we're gonna melt you and stuff I ain't
about that madman I hope that you go in
the microwave okay well this is 1 cup so
1/2 cup would be half of this right
right looks like half the me and you go
oh ok
whoopsies ear real melted put you right
there I think we're gonna have to put
this in the blender
ok I'll show you how to sift what you
know about sip spit City
not a whole lot come on this area great
you're worthless
looks like a little snow smoker look
sifted to me that doesn't look like very
much oh you know why cuz it says 1 and a
half cups idiot
just kidding we need one more Cup
perhaps I am about that measuring life I
mean look what a teaspoon looks like
that's a half teaspoon
oh that's a teaspoon I need some more
stuff even though we're not about that
measuring life you look good
maybe a little more myself go how many
tips now fifty now let's get it out now
sift it out that looks like a little bit
better oh no it was a half test not a
full test screw these directions I
should probably read them okay
half cups and you go half cup looks good
to me
I want a real real urilla really want a
button ahh look at it it's doing it
when is so easy hey this looks great and
now we'll put our ketchup in 1/4 cup
that looks like 1/4 cup I ate about that
measure in life that's not so good
cuz I'm welcome out to get this out of
this bottom now those sticks I'm gonna
get this all out hey just ate use a
blender sure good idea idiot
whatever alright no camera just fell on
the toaster this is not right I mean is
this right is it right I put a little
too much of something and not enough of
something else we're gonna have to put
some more butter in here you go you just
you cook that up real nice shut up I get
it oops left the fridge open that butter
is not melted if you wanna be my lover
you gotta make me some cookies see look
we just need a little more love my arm
is tired look I'm just helping you out
bud makes you walk through a chunk of
butter right here so we're gonna take
this as we don't need you anymore
so I'll just deposit you into the trash
drop tablespoonfuls onto baking sheets
with parchment paper I don't have that
we're gonna have to skip the parchment
paper this smells like ketchup this does
not look like the pictures
that's a spoonful
what cooking a to cookie goes a chunk of
butter we'll just not include that get
on our I'm gonna need another pan pretty
sure another big chunk of butter right
there well just scoop around it okay I
only fit six cookies on the sheet do
just that
oh well that's real sticky I don't think
that works the way that they were
planning it so that one a little too
much oh boy oh all right so I'm gonna
have to do this probably few more times
because this pan is full there's only
the trophy's on your so I'm gonna pop
this in the oven for how long eight to
ten minutes okay let's put her in the
oven all right 10-15 minutes and you are
mine all right you guys we'll take a
peek of these cookies they are massive a
cookie cookies cookies okay cookies are
ready to be taken out of the up I think
they're done oh my god it smells like
ketchup I think they're done I guess I
should probably put them on a cooling
rack the only problem was I didn't have
a cooling rack so what I decided me is
instead of a cooling rack is this what
you put silverware in I am crafting I
think we should put a little bit of
ketchup on them looks good looks great
what's on what did you use tell me the
recipe I can't tell you yet hold on okay
face test time are you ready for this
they look good presented nicely what's
in it I can tell you you can guess it's
mostly a peeler cookie but why is
there's a ketchup on business it's a lot
better than bulldozing then it's not
that it's actually it's all right
there's ketchup on it yeah a lot of it
you really wouldn't go tell it's
actually kind of good out there
oh well it looks it does look good I can
actually eat this whole cookie that's a
compliment
yeah I didn't screw it up I still ain't
about that measuring life haha this is
good
yay the first thing you ever did that
was good that you made out of all these
things well thank you thanks for
watching let me know what you'd like to
see me cook next and be sure to check
out my t-shirts because we've got I ate
about that her life t-shirts and we have
cups and a spray you know we have all
measuring vices up yeah but I don't like
to miss oh you guys Alexis